you
I learned chasity
in tournaments until I was 12 maybe
maybe
I of 12
think it was
April 1991 my first over the board
tournament
all right let's let's have some fun here
in this Swiss 3/2
round one
let's see
all right efore let's go with the
caro-kann so unlike those previous games
we do have some
increment
caro-kann
it's an unusual third move
unusual because I get to take and then
develop my knight attacking the bishop
and the bishop has to move again
I have seen this variation though
Bishop goes back to f3 and the night
goes to e2
if the bishop backs off
capturing on d4 alright let's still play
it
oh it should be played in the karo get
the bishop contributing before e6 is in
there
castles all right um I'm going to go
with Bishop here
yeah I think I was going to be a bit
tricky for me to break with c5 now that
the bishop is here let's connect Knights
move order move order move order I
wonder if maybe this was better first
let's do it now
of app in generating a threat ducks
let's go here questioning the bishop
immediately
back off or not okay it's going there
it's Castle
pulling this very fast
check isn't something you really want to
do okay I'm retreating these last couple
moves do I have to react to that I think
so let's go back a hair
this one step and now this break
mmm-hmm I guess I'm in there I'm gonna
go with this rook I'm giving up a knight
any idea to maybe play with the a pond
and yeah I think it's important to have
the rooks potentially both centralized
right now threatening Knight takes e5
this this D pawn is pinned okay they're
defending that I could consider this
move
maybe you know what's my follow-up
though after night here Bishop there
I'm not sure what my follow-up is
you
and I still try to soften things up here
or am I just subjecting myself to some
pressure
now you have to play this
I guess now my rook kind this rook move
does not feel like it contributed at all
if my opponents able to just play this
and parry my threat I don't know
I'm gonna throw the knight in there
try and get some exchange I am hitting a
lot and there I'm taking like this I
take like this I don't like that this
pawn is has a move I want to keep it
frozen I'll go here I might want to put
the night on f8 Bishop on f6 because
only only one of these two can make use
of f6 the bishop might be a pretty good
piece okay
you
I feel like my opponents making some
pretty good moves here I guess we're
gonna take get my queen here soon I have
to watch out for sacrifices maybe down
the line I can look forward to having
the better bishop but for right now I'm
more concerned about my opponent having
some pressure on my Kings side yeah
so ma'am I'm feeling the pressure
I am definitely feeling the pressure
Wow
giving up upon
think I think my opponents gonna win
upon by four somehow or another so IRA
me this is actually a good move
it's I'm not losing a pawn because I
have some tricks here maybe this is a
best move
just moving my knight
huh it maybe maybe well that was a that
wasn't me
back off maybe even this kind of stuff
a queen gonna play here
and then the accidents going to happen
on this square my bishop is a good piece
in controlling the night tonight is not
easily kicked as here get out of the pin
I'm a step away from maybe g6 I think
I'm defending
f 3 night back Queen here maybe the
night goes back even more I'm defending
but I'm solid
and again this long-term stuff might be
I'd be good okay
they've taken their foot off the gas I
think I want to sneak over a hair to a
protected square and now I'm ready for
this and then get the Queen's off you
know they are making some nice progress
here okay whoa I could triple isolate
their pawns
take the queen I'll see think anything
better than that
and now get this bishop contributing
right here and die
and I think my first threat okay I could
take care of its check let's just go
here time time time still on this let's
put more pressure on it so I've now
turned the tables some let's take with
the rook mind a lot of other stuff okay
now this is definitely winning I'm up to
clean pawns
it's not easy the games still continue
okay now my opponent did resign who had
a lot of pressure
oh there's a lot a lot of players who
have entered here very nice turn I think
it's this is the the biggest turnout so
far for a swiss awesome 137 are in here
I did learn that there is a not that
it's going to factor in for this
tournament or anything but there is a
limit apparently on the number that
could enter into a Swiss and it's 500
from what I hear
alright so there are still a lot more
games going on
eight more well let's have a look at one
of them still going on here this one is
between JC King playing as white against
Abe test two four seven
how is this one going to shape up still
Sharma is still very sharp
nyow now it's dead hitting the night on
that back rank there that ponds gonna
promote yeah there's a queen on the
scene that night is not going to be
tricky enough
and on the nights
there's no stalemates you could play the
king over mmm
tough first round let's go back to the
Hermant there's only one game going on
let's have a look at it living off of
the increment to be expected in these
final games and I moved 58 Willie grouse
one against rat Mannix
white is up a rook
rook versus two pawns and bounce this
should be a win for Willie gross one
trying to get the Queens off
could grab that pawn okay he's going
hunting for this pawn now we'll get it
coordination still going for Queen
exchange now's the time take it
big rating difference this would not be
the first upset
I mean I
Honan could have somehow
I felt some serious kingside pressure in
that my first game
not easy at all
neveress
Oh a repetition
huh
threefold repetition that one in Dez's
draw roof okay
well all games from round one are in the
books
if you want to jump in you could late
joined you probably want to sneak in
right now though don't miss out on more
than one round
it's time to make up ground
let's see 144 now in there I should be
getting paired with someone with one
point let's have a look at another page
page two
not too many are in paws mode the last
last Swiss that I ran
a lot were in paws mode not the case
here so let us see who we get in round
two of nine
okay tick V
all right let's try D for against tick V
ah okay
focused you could only focus on this one
game so let's let's make it count
that's that's really one of the one of
the things I'm really enjoying about the
Swiss compared to the arena just the you
only have one game per round and you
gotta just focus on that one game block
everything else out no berserk
none of this let's try and get a quick
game in get a lot of games in no just
like over the board chess
let's put the bishop here
you
all right I was thinking they could
maybe try and get away with the pawn
grab
you
but no not going for that all right I
think
white has a very good position now
what do I like about my position
currently this guy a little more
aggressive than this guy that's the
imbalance pawn wise and we may have an
additional inbounds coming up
and we do
activity
you
so what do we do now is why we try to
get in b5 and I think we're able to get
that in mm-hmm
plaque interfering with this idea
but
loses a pawn in the process no I could
take that name probably should it's
chopped
I want to chop again
you
you
this move is appealing I'm going to say
this pawn isn't going to go oh hang on
hang on hang on this Bishop may defend
the pawn if I take it
no no no no no let's take this first
my rook is trying to go into pacman mode
for right now
you
but take c6 possibly
maybe
like doesn't even try to hang on to this
pile I don't I don't know I can't even
defend that pond King here is running
into 95 with check more fuel on c6
bishop here hits my rook
and then if I take this pawn king here
my rook is not trapped I have this chemo
which would be winning the bishop
defending my rogue kicking in the King
away from hitting my rook a lot of good
stuff is happening with a 95 in short
in the tank
what to watch out about castles castles
I'd get forked
you
rocks hit
you
under a minute top spot for team black
okay I'm diving in
so
I guess they're okay with me taking here
and my wreck is gonna be a little
[Music]
short on squares I guess
if I go here there's King here
interesting
suppose I take this pawn though
yeah I'm gonna take this pawn it's a
pawn I hit the rook I'm also ready to
bring this rook here or my bishop on f4
checks the king but I think more
important point is that it stops the
rooks from pivoting on b8
you
all right let's give this check first
they're going to hit my rook
guess here maybe maybe this could be a
move I'm providing some security over b3
the rook is still under fire in d6 d6 is
a huge square can pivot about on I think
I see a clean way forward diving in here
also restricting moves let's let's go
here with check and I think I'm just
going to take with my bishop this is
something to maybe consider but I think
this is cleanness keep the structure as
is
make a forceful move and then look to
restrict
these to this position is know very well
are very much under control not going to
castle let's back off control the night
and I could still look forward now that
I've consolidated here
thwarted any any any threats against my
king I can now look for this break b5
alright that night
I may want to just take so he get in b5
oh no no yeah I just take and then I
could take here I'm winning a rook
oh no they could take with the rook just
thinking that you have to take with the
king all right this is still the way
forward
this could be a move
that looks fun - I could take that pun
let's take with the rope keep the file
opened
yeah
[Music]
it's going to give the check first
and then take care hit the rook
and we're gonna get the rook fork
alright they resigned good game good
game
tick V there's still a lot of games
going 160 are in there
awesome in awesome awesome turnout all
right so let's have a look at a game
Rondo
playing against mappy
under 20 move 34 okay at night and
is to Brooks you're gonna give some
material away
rook takes night here or not
check ooh ooh ooh the Knights gonna live
Black has at least two per pet no blacks
probably gonna give me ya blacks gonna
be giving me very soon
that's the better square otherwise
there's Queen check here she getting
made it by force yes very nice sequence
there checking his way to check mate
okay that was checkmate okay one move
later
he got that one black got that one still
16 games going for round one 15 now
let's have a look at another one Alex
triple zeros
up the exchange a clean exchange
and white seems to be doing well here
yes with this last move creating in a
new file for the rooks this guy's pretty
active this guy not so much
stuck behind his own pawns looking to
focus on g7 we'll get that
you
right
be careful maybe you don't want this to
happen he's getting the bishop very nice
he's going to be up a full rock very
soon white
check
hoping for maybe this yeah white has all
the base points covered no counterplay
there black resigns still four games to
go let's have a look at this one
all right let's not why it's gonna get
this one yeah black just resigned and
only one game going this one here okay
Queen ending white up to pawns black
hoping for a perpetual are there
perpetual
this is a popular final game from a
Swiss you know just having a a queen
ending
you
all right Queen Esther blockade now
and now can we get this kind of stuff in
check here and then there
okay well that pong could have been
captured with check he's getting the
Queen's off
is this a one King and pawn ending you
can take the pawn of the Queen move fast
Ricky's taking the Queen all right let's
see if this is going to be enough should
be a win for white
a tempie can
a factor
the king there was an opportunity here
it's
you got take with the king
the king now to win
here and then pushing through white
should get this one yep that's the way
slip and Jimmy is going to get it
yes okay and that game is over
which means round two is over
ohhh-kay uh Cutlass 8 thank you for the
prime resub three months in a row no
appreciate it ma'am gar Tiger Tier one
resub 43 months in a row thank you as
well
for years nearly for you gar tiger
thank you again
all right how many have one are how many
have two points
27 players with two points after two
rounds
all right around three coming up
are we going to have a swiss bullet
titled arena
I don't know I don't think there's any
anyone upcoming that I'm aware of all
right let's see submarine 11
rusha
let's see what we get
oh also you don't lose on time if you
don't make a move after six seconds it's
just that this clock starts ticking down
just like it went over the board
okay
I guess we'll try a Sicilian
this term
and d6
my up six and a six
Sicilian I Dorf
okay
you
you
let's bring the night here
not very familiar with the black side of
this opening let's go clean b6
can end up with doubled pawns over here
okay I have an opportunity to give this
check
what
you
well that's a first
I can't highlight it but
can you read it here
she detected
victorious
you
I don't know it's very
[Music]
I don't know how to think
you
what's that about I mean if there was a
sheet detected you'd have something
there No
I don't know
that's
bizarre
maybe a maybe a bug I don't know like if
if it was if it was a cheat shouldn't it
say on the profile
I mean that's not like a new account
I've played that player a bunch of times
no no issues or anything
I hope it's just a bug and I hope the
bug is corrected fast if that is the
case so um okay well a quick
around three so I mean
how are things working then I mean Mike
is gonna be able to be paired up in
round four like cuz this is this is all
very very new so I don't know
and we're going to wear
it happens Piquet is 0-90 TV thank you
for the primary sub 21 months in a row
also new Lonnie you Beast you thank you
for the tier 1 research da months in a
row a rare pink night
yeah I don't know I'm not sure
more to add on that on that game hello
poo so tasty with the with the
highlighted message there check yourself
let's go into a game yeah let's let's do
that instead of just staring at that so
there's still a lot of games going
how's thing how are things here
you
white is in the tank black is maybe
ready to chop away on d5
winning upon all right counterpunch Oh a
very timely counterpunch yes this night
is cooked
visiting Gandhi from where Indonesia
Singapore
Singapore sorry about that Singapore
where white is up a piece now night over
it's not a full piece black has two
pawns for the night well I mean if there
is this capture there is a new new way
that this rook can maybe get active so
that's that's a nice pit stop first
demote the King and then look maybe to
go offensive
okay we do have that pig on the seventh
it's a hungry piece
okay strictly defensive so this should
be excellent for white this should be
winning for white you could try to clamp
down going for g4 first you go hunting
for the H pond
Lenna form keep it locked capturing will
open the file for the rook so that's why
I'm thinking lock it up g5 chop take
with this one so that guy's not a target
the rook will get some activity but yeah
it could be a little bit tricky to
defend both of these points this one
will fall but one of these two may fall
white still has some work to do here
and isn't this guy he thought he thought
about moving forward but then that pawn
would fall with the check okay this is
all this interesting way to defend so
these base points are covered yet but
still as soon as this rook you know
there's these checks there's maybe a
check here to black King position is
very strong
now this there's going to be a pastor
keeping it a little locked still not
sure what that move is
like isn't isn't this maybe an idea it's
giving a check ooh who is he pushing
through not not quiet you can't take
oh the rook is still there to help
defend ah very nice this should be clean
now
yeah you take with the rook a king first
and then you take here and then you go
back hunting this okay this should be
much easier now that you have to worry
there's white here about a black past
sauce a past black sea palm all right
black resigned that yeah I forgot that
the rook is still he isn't all in on
hunting that pond down okay only three
games remaining from round three let's
have a look at another one cinco path
playing as white
all right this pawn is going this way
you
two checks
you
okay
to take the night with check Oh
I think white is while white is the one
pressing now
on quality quality over quantity to
Queens now on the scene there will be no
perpetual mate right here given a given
a moment there's a mate
King is walking a tightrope
move
all right could exchange Queens it's
going form or he's going right out he's
trying to check his way to checkmate
should be able to check
like crazy two queens on this open board
yeah and that is me Ruth all right only
one game remaining and it is a rook and
pawn ending you cannot exchange rooks
it's a one King and pawn ending if you
do to keep the rooks on back off time no
time aw Walker no gas in the tank there
okay that's gonna do it for round three
it's in the books
Oh question how old was I when I hit mm
I was I think
over the board rating mm I think I was
over 20 years old
no no no no
I was about 19 I think
as about 19
yeah I hit national master when I was 24
it took me about five years to go from
expert to master so
as about 19
okay round for any second now how many
have three still 13 players with three
points let's see who we get next 176 are
in there
okay plank ax from you don't know okay
let's try
efore game
you
am i planning to go for FM now I have no
plans for
[Music]
for that I don't think I would ever plan
for that actually um I play e5 quite a
bit
let's try Knight c3 I'm inviting the win
waar
variation
you
I've played all three variations many
times
these are three replies could also go
the exchange all right so I guess we're
entering what is known as the steinitz
variation okay that's not the Stein
that's the typical follow up usually we
have this stuff happening all right so
the night dives into e4
mm-hm
um
[Music]
and I could capture it
then play Bishop III
I'm kind of more familiar with just
playing Bishop d3
along this capture cc5 maybe even c4
let's see we're gonna get a an imbalance
I expect maybe maybe maybe they go for a
pin I don't think that that's best
but
we're going to find out
no tricks on f2
Queen h4 alright so they're just gonna
pin pile up on that guy
a bishop d2 or Knight here I'm going to
say Bishop d2 because this nice favorite
square is up three
I'm RA with this this is my bad Bishop
so okay well if I take like this they
take like that pawns are doubled do I
want to just have these guys exchange I
think I do although there is a reason to
maybe take like this I'm gonna take like
this pawns are doubled but I like that I
have the tempo against the bishop and I
basically get the move back and this
move I think I could put to use
immediately or I could make good use of
this next to move is what I'm trying to
say queen g4 can hurt
this bishop should stick around
somewhere on the Kings side
because there's going to be some serious
pressure on these dark squares
this may look odd but maybe maybe is
quite a good move it's kind of tricky to
defend against queen g4 because if you
castle
if you castle you're gonna lose the
exchange so he gestured with drawers and
the bishop is withdrawn and where do we
go from here
I'm going to say oh do I still bring the
Queen here
I think I do hmm
you
No
let's put the knight on its favorite
square
it looks kinda silly to have the bishop
on the back rank but it is solid I
believe
no development for black basically but
it is a locked position until this move
so this is actually a welcome sight
yeah this position can now open up with
the capture and I think I'm going to am
I going to capture
my worried that it would be maybe locked
up no I'm not really let's kick castled
if they try to lock it up I'm gonna play
with c4
I have a way to to break open the
position all right here we go
c4 it is and c4 may happen again some
underling the pawns I think I think I
want to take right now
I may want to give some I when I might I
just want to pause for a second because
at this last move the night doesn't have
c6 and what was this Bishop doing so is
now the time to pause
um I'm gonna say yeah let's get this a
pun running maybe only after the night
makes a move will I go here and say
uh-huh you can't go to c6 anymore
so I'm maintaining the tension until I
know where this night goes okay this is
a weak square and it also may be hinting
at g5 which does concern me some
son let me retreat the night
hmm
yeah let's retreat tonight
with the nine queen h5
this move doesn't scare me too much the
king is just
asking for trouble
all right I'm really down on the clock
here all right I'm just gonna just gonna
do it
you
you
I am kind of floundering here
do not have much time
my pond is playing fast stop 95
really putting pressure on me on the
clock
really going after my king - huh
Bishop takes pawn
you
as take like this
considering rook here
scary is kind of scary
you
and I don't know how significant that
pond is but
let's see I owe the
together
only four seconds
it's tense man it's very tense
given the exchange right now giving some
material right back
get the rook
you
just want to take this pawn
are getting the rook
you
stuff in here my King might have to take
a hike
defend this check
alright I'm good be able to get here now
there are no good checks
check and then we should have makin a
couple could only block with the Queen
made on g7 huh or keine
game is this it's crazy look at these
guys King went on castled and then these
pawns got launched at my king
taking upon all the way out here in
left-field just ignoring this these pawn
pushes but I guess it's this guy is not
factoring in and I don't know I was
under a lot of pressure there good game
plank ax
whoo okay
still games going in round four Kovac
let's see
white should be able to get this one
yeah no no targets for the bishop and
snipe will flush the King back
and you could force this pawn a light
square first yeah now it's now it's
clean mm-hmm I like the idea of keeping
the knight here
keeping if the knight is here in the
pawn is here the King only has these two
squares and they can't be obstructed oh
this is clean - yeah very nice because
that pawn was threatening to push
through if you didn't take the knight
and it's a one King and pawn ending
White has the opposition
yep
the last thing to note is that after
okay kikyo king here
there yeah if if the King win
this and then that you go to the rook
file alright two games remaining
kappa our new libra against kappa
can punt ending black should be getting
this one rook ideally placed behind the
passer
and this guy's going to roll
here here they are here
you know the pun pushes through
it's gonna get this one no mates to be
worried about as black
check just move up the checks run out
check check resigner maybe
you
more checks okay-y resigned view the
tournament okay that was the last one
one more to go
I'm actually thinking about it yeah I
may I may be checking out the car oh and
Magnus thing tomorrow we'll see
okay round four in the books five
players with four points
how many would three and a half five six
players with three and a half
eleven players without without a loss so
far
181 are in there
I'm around five let's see who we get
all right
hello Yoshi squad okay Cinco Cinco PAP
all right let's go with d6 bishop in
early bishop deployment
all right
I'll golfer fianchetto now that I know
the bishop is here I'm trying to get
this move in
with tempo and so I'm delaying Knight f6
and given some early information about
the bishop and there's a nice prize once
you play e5 in this case the prize is a
tempo
right now we have this I have to decide
how to block
actually welcome to a dark square bishop
exchange normally not a good idea but I
think it is I think it is fine to do
this develop my night clean on e6 I have
very nice control over the dark squares
so and the bishop is the most efficient
defender of the dark squares but I have
a solid pawn on e5 Knights around I
could defend my king should he come
under any fire let's go with the Queen
first I have a better Bishop this is
something I can look forward to some
fixed pawns a knight on c5 can be good
um I think this is fine also this is a
nice flight square for my king all right
I don't move forward here are there any
holes in White's position d4 is not a
hole I'd love to see a move like this
start eliminating pieces that control d4
and throw a knight there I also look at
this move I think I'm leaning towards
moving this Knight now let's move this
night until this Knight moves
oh wait I got here how how annoying is
maybe 9c for okay I have pressure on me
from generating a threat
all right yeah this guy needs to move
before my Queen site could be developed
unless I want to do this I don't know
what I I don't I don't think I want to
do that I want to have this option
opened pin the night
I don't know how annoying it would be
I may just want to
exchange bishop for night and still try
to play towards a superior night a good
night versus bad bishop stuff let's see
I think I want to pin now oh no no no
this this is just like that early bishop
move had me drawn towards a leaf I've
now now I'm seeing this with tempo
against the Queen so I think white needs
to keep my knight out of f4 and at the
same time white doesn't want to do that
because then I have an additional spot
for my Bishop and the pin could be that
much more annoying actually gg3 bishop
here there is no h3 anymore if g3 is in
Oh
going on if my opponent doesn't have a
dark square bishop around in this
structure circling into f4 can be that
much more powerful moving forward I
think I should dive in right now
yeah let's do it can see a variation
where the Queen gets trapped okay let's
throw some heat on this bishop
now let's do it rook here still unclear
where I want to go with my bishop they
want to have this move in reserve well
I'm the bishop right now maybe maybe
he's ready to back off that's that seems
sensible stuck the bishop away
kick my knight okay
I don't think there's any tricks here
let's get out of a pin let's keep this
move
let's have f6 available if I need it
to secure you five I don't know if I
want to be a babysitter my queen wants
to babysit all day
so alright I'm expecting that if I play
Bishop to g4 it'll be questioned
immediately yes still huh what other
moves do I have here maybe maybe I play
No
you
I guess we're going to go for this move
sacrifices on this square
yeah it's going to trade and I think f6
here or should I just try and stabilize
my night
it might be going for this I think I'm
weakening my King position a little bit
but I think if I play 85 there's g3 and
if I take King g2 my knight is stuck so
there's also starting to kind of put the
foot up foot on the gas here some
pressure on the clock I'm feeling so I
could always retreat or maybe even still
think about capturing because I have
this square secured Brooke still
fighting along the D file how to improve
further I'm looking at pawn play do I
want to go any further
[Music]
let's go here if rook takes rook I could
take with the Queen okay
let's get this night
let's get this night here
alright I'm getting a rocked back
yes continue to get rocked back
I'm on b4
I want to take it I'm feeling I may have
yikes
putting a lot of pressure on me
on my knight right here
there any tricks
you
okay ooh
that's a mistake my knight has a huge
square enough for
take here c3a have Queen c5
Queen III I have I have some tricks
let's go here still living off of the
increment
target g21 de-centralized the queen g3s
squares while oh I'm also paving the way
for rook a one
if we could target this square as well
threatening mate threatening this
check there's something better
thought I was winning upon
there's a really bad decision why am i
giving up my strong night for that
Bishop they didn't take my night
what were they check can can always hide
here he's hiding and we should have may
next sack the clean are there any
stalemate tricks now cuz I'm recapturing
with Chuck mate poof
it's not it's not fun living off of the
increment for that long but it's there
still have to find good moves right made
on board
man okay let's see game shiny shiny
Xiang mmm this could still be tricky for
white
this could still be tricky I don't know
how to call this one pushing through
the best white might have is a draw
Sulli ready to promote it you might have
to go back and forth like this think
it's a draw
yeah not easy
okay two games remaining
Cutlass eight playing white house white
looking here okay you can't take that
guy cuz of this but now it's a threat
okay's eliminating me what was that a
night so you could get that pond now the
bishop is hit got three passers one will
fall blacks should be able to get this
the bishop will hunt these will at least
be in a spot to stop them from promoting
easily and these guys should be much
much faster
tingled hide right here Bishop will
block probably move forward there keep
that strong king position
and some checks there's another check
here but
I just kept rolling with these guys
go
go go
one step maybe that was a mouse slip
okay oh he's just one upon a pond is
down
tricks yet okay oh now you can simplify
okay to clean ponds
like is gonna get this one final game
yes that was the final game okay two
players with five I know who I'm getting
visiting Gandhi and I will meet in this
very important round six of nine let's
see how it goes
you
you
you
what is the increment the increment is
two seconds three minutes with the two
second increment right here
no I didn't watch the banter blitz today
I did catch Magnus streaming last night
some that was fun
you
okay here we go
around 6:00 I don't think I've played
visiting Gandhi nope didn't think so
let's go it's d4 let's try not to live
off of the increment either we can Dutch
hit with the Dutch
being Quetta or not being keto okay I'm
going to be aggressive with this pawn
and get the bishop here and I like this
idea Bishop c4 words check
all right that
[Music]
believe it is important too
maintain my pawn on the square or maybe
there's this this could be sensitive I'm
gonna say let's still play within this
structure my bishop will be unprotected
on a one but I don't think he could be
exploited knight c6 could be strong
possibly
I'm not a bishop there I think this guy
still belongs here I would not mind
seeing this move because then my Knights
eye is open my bishops eyes and I want
to try to develop a plan to get to this
square so Bishop belongs here pretty
annoying piece to deal with
there's no 97 for example okay that this
is already a gap now basically I only do
I want to capture and then play here
have it open it up open it up just a
little bit on the Queen side
now let's just keep this guy here
um
I'm gonna say no I think I'd feel some
pressure against b4 and it could be a
bit
defend you can see this kind of pressure
on there at night there
you
maybe that's going to happen anyhow the
night going to a six
I'd like my night here a night on c4
would be excellent
maybe I could oh can I not grab this
pond
and take it means not there so you can
come back and win it but it takes some
time
you
I'm a really big square in e5 now that's
the that's the one thing I'm really
seeing
okay they're capturing
I think I want to just take that night
he's too good gotta go oh you're opening
up the Queen like that okay
three four
can't be stopped g5 isn't there in time
every piece I want on e5
this guy is behind his own pawns there
could be some pressure on b4 Bishop here
convenient defense
here the night I'll have a square but
it's not a hole there's also that square
yes it's very maneuvering a very
maneuvering type game I may still dive
in
let's go here prepare to challenge a
rook
see I think rook a for
move look forward to this 95 move for
sure also okay so get a rock offer
change one Rock
both major pieces too to fall off I'm
actually looking at rook a five even as
an exchange sacrifice
look super appealing I have some dark
square control I'm going to go for it
I'm gonna hope that my nights
can do some damage and I can maybe pivot
on beef or I could pivot on b4 and
weasel my queen in there somehow
h4 to soften up the kingside okay they
don't want that rook at least just yet
I'm weakening my light squares but this
guy I don't I don't know if he'll be
able to control those squares so here we
are
now that
okay I think now is where we dive in
with
I was hoping that that pond wouldn't
fall so fast
okay this move I think is key
so after chop chop I want to be able to
play here not have a check and I have
time to go here otherwise there's a
check my King goes here and then there's
Queen Fe and I say stop my queen from
invading their house
I want my queen to be somewhere around
here generating a threat and then I
could look to circle in my Knights
something like that so I want to get
this in with tempo hitting the rook and
basically my queen is activated now so
oh they have that move which I did not
see
okay
well is there another way in
I'm gonna go here first I'm not sure
what squares my knight wanting my
Knights want to go too maybe maybe I
should have played here I'm not sure
here rook here there's this
if my queen ki get active I think this
should be very good for me okay they're
just capturing that is I was not
expecting that
all right I think I
i'ma put this night here
it's tough it's tough it's tough my
queen can maybe sneak in this way too
let's put this night here
they can maybe break down my king
position
I don't know I might have to try it like
this
and I can get to f4 my king is secure
the rook is just retreating
let's put this night here
you
they're just trying to sacrifice right
back okay let's let's not allow that
let's also keep him around stopping this
past pawn ok Queen exchange
let's go here
being an eye on the B Foursquare oh
there's a check on an f3
yeah
that could definitely be trouble
[Music]
I guess here yeah that's that's tough
now that could be activated
time
maybe I don't know can I get this moving
I'll just clean up three my queen needs
to be over here okay they're softening
softening up my position I think I did
take I don't know I don't have any time
you
still tricky still tricky maybe a check
I have this square covered stopping
clean f3
here I have a check
in a sacrifice back let's give this
check first
and a take by getting in there
coupons but I have I'm only down one
pond now
here
[Music]
at any time
get that pun
you
you
I'll go for more uh my cards this square
on the bishop in the pond
oh this check
I missed that check
they're getting a queen I can't do
anything with my queen now oh I was so
close
I'm just going to get made
that's me oh I tried I tried I tried
Bishop H Bishop a6 ah very nice game
done better here
who
well I could have repeated I didn't I
didn't see the bishop move here I could
have gone for maybe repetition ah I
didn't see that check that was a killer
it's winning you know for sure it's just
winning you're getting Queen g1 a very
good game visiting Gandhi good game
alright there are still five going let's
have a look at one of them
lank 39 against Shawn Ishaan
could I have blocked with the night I
could have blocked with the night but I
wanted to keep my night around to I want
to keep the night close to their king
Thank You X sub ster X for the prime sub
13 in a row now our 13 months
total foreigner Oh No preciate it man
you
you
you
you
all right
you
well I should get this right now the
king is hmm [ __ ] should this be Hogan
for black maybe this is a draw
as black make progress
like may have to bring the King around
like here
because the rooks always in a spot to
give
like as soon as this happens the King
takes
it's tough to establish a strong King
position
check might be threefold repetition
yeah he's gonna try to sneak around like
this I guess
get to f1 or e1 start hinting at this
advance
he's trying it
you
I wonder in my game if I could have
if I could have hung on to my a pond for
just a little bit more to buy me some
time to activate my queen towards their
king I couldn't get my queen activated I
was really close really close it should
be a draw
rook is there in time that pawn will be
one
yeah that's that King position was too
strong the White King block hating both
pawns a draw on board all right and that
is the last one from round six so only
one player with six points visiting
Gandhi six out of six outlier
five-and-a-half goal pot five-and-a-half
top three not a single loss poha vaq I
might be getting paired with you or
maybe somebody one of the five and a
half
we're going to find out on a player's
with five still the first page five or
more
I'm right Gandhi is killing it I agree
I'm aware of the drama but I don't
follow it too too closely
your rank your ANCA
you're an for sure okay I'm this player
was a five and a half or so they're on
it they're on a roll only a draw
um okay let's go
t6e five and
[Music]
five
just move all your pawns
I'm also going to go with this
it's not I don't know just move your
pawns g5 when is it going to stop right
here I've had my fun early on I've
acquired some nice queenside space and
we're gonna go for this he's going to be
kicked
castled
I want to keep the square open once he's
kicked here 97
you
ninety-seven f4 and
this can be a nice a nice idea also once
once I am controlling H for this G for
move starts to be a threat because
Knight h4 is no longer a good reply
also this night doesn't have this pivot
anymore
I'm gonna play this move right now
actually the bishops eyes are open
potentially to this square I'm going to
go here also now that this pawn is here
if white tries to challenge it with e3
white gets squeezed with g4 and then f3
and the bishop is forever cornered so a
case in point right here boom
they're going for a sacrifice of a minor
piece to illuminate two ponds but this
bishop is squashed now because of this
timely g4 and this early pond place
seems to be paying off at this moment
getting the pond into f3 is there
anything better
I don't think so okay so
I have a huge space advantage I have
what I think is a winning position
how do how to best make use of this
space advantage
we have
to single
a single thing
I'm sorry I was thinking about building
a center but I'm kind of bringing the
rook to life so maybe I think I open up
the center
I'm okay here's a way I can look at it
let's play this first here's a way it
can look at it
my opponent basically doesn't have a lie
square bishop in this position so let's
let my light square bishop be brought to
life
and start to have some influence on the
light squares so both both of these
diagonals are pretty appealing the beef
I'll have to worry about I should
probably take with the Queen
yeah I'm gonna keep my knight around
on this up six square not sure what
prospects it would have once on this
square generating a threat just looking
to complete development
I'll stay off of f5 most likely I'd run
into a fork but I keep pressure here
we get to an open file this night is
okay this is welcome welcome site ending
the Queen's off yeah let's take and I'm
gonna play here opening up the bishops
eyes and posing a very important
question now to white if you don't take
here there's no way to successfully try
a piece sacrifice you're not getting two
pawns for the minor so that pawn
basically has to go and I think
I can now expect a sacrifice very soon
on this square that's that's going to
happen next
not too much I could do about that maybe
maybe maybe I can actually maybe I
insert Bishop e6 first
I could try to get
something going here let's try this move
first there should be six rook here I
could take they could take here I feel
like I should have something oh oh you
know what I could have this move Oh a
knight on h3 is mate rook here here rook
takes pawn Knight here
then they have to play this just so the
king has air the rook or bishop can't
move a night on g5 can be fantastic okay
well if I take the rook the knight is
pulled away from this square so the
there is no piece Accra Feist on f3
anymore
you
fan of that
I'm playing up a piece basically one two
three four versus one two three
this cannot be disrupted
and I should go on the offensive here
this rook cannot go too far or theirs
back rank maid so it's it's basically
these two pawns restrict the King and
Bishop King Bishop and rook which is
surprising isn't it in a way like that's
how that's how valuable this this
structure is mating ideas the rook has a
defensive role
so what I have highlighted it's
basically offset I feel in a way that
I'm playing with three minor pieces
versus just these two as long as I could
keep things under control and I believe
I can and I don't think there's any
reason not to just go pluck upon maybe
there is let's back up they might try to
chip away
have this square available
let's simplify some more
take with the king
now this is a threat I really even care
about that though
let's activate the rook
very simpler way
you
let's activate the rook
there's no there's no
my night here
so now we're looking at this
Knight is under control two-to-one
majority on the Queen side
let's get him rolling I could have won
this pawn as well
now they're just in a giant pickle
right there
not sure what to suggest here for why
you
a pair could win the night now
still the same story with that
okay let me just push through
yeah they resigned it's really dating
back to this moment here after e3 I
think it might be lost
maybe important to already have done
something other than Bishop d2 at this
stage and then I mean maybe this was
already kind of a little a little too
scary for white
okay seven games still going let's have
a look at one of them visiting Gandhi
outlier King and pawn ending how do we
assess this outliers playing as white
blacks gonna get it he has opposition
visiting Gandhi is going to move to
seven out of seven fantastic what's
those performance 26:35 awesome m3 games
still going
P sitter
upon ending
should be draw withdraw the rook there
it is
now is the the drawing way some checks
from behind no way to make progress for
black as soon as the rug leaves here the
King improves
how do I feel about the surge in
popularity of chess on Twitch awesome I
love it
you
it's great for the game
more eyes on the game we love
this will be a draw soon enough
all right two games remaining
voluntary
playing his white rule nothing
now the rook and pawn ending
how to finally push through at this
point I think you want to rock off can
we get one rook up
oh you can win this palm
after king there that cut like on could
have been captured
he's trying to get a rock off
oh look at that that was sneaky no now
he's ready to push
likes gonna get this now I think there
might be a tricky try
there could have been there could have
been this if you promote there's that
and you get the queen
worth a shot
still had some time
white weight all not too much time but
it was worth a shot okay only one game
going one game remaining Willie Grasso
see this is all very familiar to me
these the Swiss tournament these these
remaining games are what you would see
over the board
you know rook and pawn ending a game
where it's a rook versus a knight only
making two one two
Willie gross one kumamoto
right not the most efficient way to
tackle this ending but black is going to
get there
eventually
my favorite Sicilian I don't think I
have a favorite Sicilian
the dragon I could actually say the
dragon is my least favorite I don't like
to play it or play against it
now this one isn't going to be a 50 move
rule the night was just captured maybe
dozen moves back
you
you
alright mate on board and with that
around a seven is in the books
visiting Gandhi seven out of seven
fantastic
well done there is a streamers battle
coming up - on June 7th so feel free to
you you are invited to play
if you would like to
chest network is one of the teams
competing again
finished a ninth out of ten last time
Popovic played in the last one
Kovach by the way I think I might just
be paired up against you in this 8th
round we're gonna find out Ozma Hovick
doing 23:29 performance
okay let us see round eight here we go
alright
let's try efore
let's quote the knight on c3 what was
our game we didn't play that long ago
I think it was I think this is our
second time playing in a Swiss
four nights
are out and about
I guess we're entering a scotch
I should be four
is what I expect alright let's chop
offend capture
so
and start with the pin
I guess my opponent seems to know this
much better than me
let's put the Queen on f3
yes uh by half
they're playing
I guess the flight square and also stop
Bishop to g4 development with tempo rook
b8 b3
or I want my rocks
okay now all right so let's back off
here so I guess there's not going to be
rugby aid at least right now
there is Bishop d6 yes but hmm
but what
all right I would love to have my clean
here and my night here establish a dark
square blockade not easy to do though
all right how's this position going to
shape up shortly we're going to have the
dark square bishop soft but what I like
to have happen
or would I like to be
seems to slow like a threes always met
with a five
you
you
maybe okay this looks very
try to get in B for whether a three or
it to be one I guess there's still this
a five move I would like to see this
capture as it helps my queen okay this
this is actually
allowing this b4 move and I probably
should just go forward with it
yeah let's go forward with that my night
is hanging well my night is unprotected
so it could be vulnerable I could just
have a little bit more time my nights
ready to circle in here I'm pretty sure
a five should be played
now a5 a3
rook aids-free my night is fine going
here because he's eyeing up a nice
square on c5 so really getting the night
to one of these twos is a nice
improvement this guy is under control
about my bishop listen yeah the night is
under control there may be some tricks
here actually so if they try to put some
pressure on f4 I could take the h6 pawn
I could consider that at least winning
upon it's probably good maybe not
and then there's this
check in that position
no take age sex but okay
now I could take age six and be
threatening mate I'd have to calculate
so
taking so no tricks there and now Brooke
the air so I'm getting what I want
should probably get here right now
although queen d4 is immediately
challenged with Queen b6
I have night here though I want my night
on c5 when night a 494 is this going to
be a move
yeah I'm gonna go here I do not want to
see this advance because it gives a huge
square to both minor pieces and that
would be too much yeah so I guess I'm
just like you can't have it all huh if I
could get these two moves in I think
it's excellent for four why I think this
is a necessity
to try and pose some problems okay a
five is also a move but it's not as
scary anymore though because Queen b6 I
could take and there's no recapture
controlling c5
so it just be a a queen exchange but
there's no repair that that occurs of
the c5 square with the Queen exchange
so and here we are we take
we circle the night in here and we're
also ready to play c3 I'm also ready to
play c3 and probably should play that
next because still I should be watchful
of a d4 break
still it's not easy it is not easy let's
go see three first and I think I'm
a-okay they're just moving the night
okay well let's go with f4 I'm stopping
this and actually threatening f5 winning
the bishop and I'm also paving the way
from a king to blockade on these dark
squares a lot of dark square talk c 5 c
5 d 4
Knight is currently competing here they
could challenge by night
g4i could insist on f5 or simply take
steps in the direction of establishing a
king in the center
you
would they be considering that moon
if I played this there's f5 I don't know
let's just improve my king I think that
that's best
Roka there you know
you
let's go here okay my king is sliding in
I think important to double possibly
well sooner King on d4 Knight on c5
they double a little like soon I'm not
going to have time for these two moves
so for K 7 what am i doing I might enjoy
I might just need to dive in even though
I would take on doubled doubled see
ponds so I don't want to end up in some
uncomfortable panel oh they went to the
wrong square maybe a mouse slip maybe
they wanted rook to a7
a sudden end
okay round eight is in the books let's
see Kovac has the tough the tough
pairing here but Popovic is up upon
okay well the structure has changed now
there's a passed pawn on the e-file for
Popovic and a two-to-one majority over
here but Popovic sking is cut off how do
we get this guy back into play okay well
this first you can maybe start making
some inroads these guys are scary though
I don't know how to assess this one this
wasn't tricky this one's very tricky
he had the white king position I think
this is I mean Y could win this
even though White's down upon
like in that 1-1 game we were watching
the the strong kingpost stopping both
both passed pawns this this is a rock
alright he is he is gonna be able to
scoop this pawn up will he be there in
time he is gonna be there in time may be
important to take there first with check
and then here and then here oh but he's
not gonna be there in time if you take
here push and then there's a rip block
you could push the timing was not right
visiting Gandhi's gonna get this one
let's see if these let's see if he could
maybe work some magic with these ponds
we saw one earlier where was a knight
and some ponds and there was just a
perpetual there
but this shouldn't be enough let's see
I woulda thought go here
yeah and black resigned this one's gonna
fall they're just not far enough
advanced to pose any trap tough ending
very tough ending Gandhi
eight out of eight
awesome let's have
the one two remaining length 39 against
Rhetta BAM how are things looking here
white is up the exchange and a pawn rook
and pawn versus Bishop in balance
that looks pretty sweet to watch out for
stalemates
okay time out why wins one game
remaining rook and pawn ending black is
up a rook in three pawns
chan
as invoker one on his black
hello little turd in the chat
I see you
the Ralph and Toric's thank you for the
tier 1 risa two months now
you had hey Jerry would love to see you
take on Eric Rosen and a chest boxing
match can we make that happen I don't
think that that's gonna happen
what is Erica fan of chess boxing that's
news to me I didn't know or you're just
a fan of Eric Rosen as am i as I am
you're not here for the good grammar are
you let us see be careful no stalemates
should have made next uh-oh Oh Stan
matrix watch out for the Eric Rosen
stalemate made on g2 many different
mates they're here here they are okay
that's the last one
final round coming up another smooth one
no no hiccups it is going to finish I
have seven out of eight visiting Gandhi
who is gonna beat up visiting Gandhi
who's gonna get paired with them he's
already played outlier I believe yep so
it's looking like Shawnee Shan you're
gonna get the tough one
Shawny sean has not lost
few draws wins very good performance
2269 let's see
visiting gandhi is in their 2665 I'm in
their 2453 outlier 23:44 Kovac 2291 all
right final round let's make it a good
one
hope you're all getting some good games
in there out liar
all right final game oh I remember that
game okay let's not do that same opening
it was a d4 opening we played recently
so I remember that one let's shift gears
all right
[Music]
let's play something that's very odd
polish I'm giving my opponent a big
a big square early-on big weakness to
work with I'm playing this right now
because if here I have C 5 D 6 isn't in
just yet ok so they're developing the
Queen
you
the night out
and the other night out
like a giant like I I could but I could
jump in it's what I wanted to say let's
continue to develop I was thinking about
jumping into d5 now yeah
what about now
I do it now I have to be careful I don't
end up in a situation where they take
the night out and where they take the
night out and you know end up with the
piece on this square that I cannot
challenge
okay
check you say
all right isn't that night gonna
struggle a little bit you gotta take
here yes you can jump in there you go
home
I think it's important that I play this
this move if they go back otherwise I
think this is I think this is going to
happen no matter what I know
I like my position okay they're jumping
in I like my position now let's see I
could castle
I don't think I could track this pond
down I could only ever add one attacker
conveniently the Queen but how else
do I increase the pressure on d4 I don't
see it so
thank f4
five Bishop here takes takes if Bishop
here I can castle and if they take
they're gonna be in a pin I think I
should start with that for
I should really try to make sure my
bishop can find a productive role and I
think it's going to be on f3
yeah
take with the pawn
let's G three of Queen h4 bat move
sure though no
I need to get this guy and I guess I'm
going to give up this pawn
I cannot allow this or can i if I Castle
in this then that the rook moves this
pawn lives this pawn has passed this
pawn has to go
gotta go alright rook takes f4 King sigh
Castle queenside castle generates a
threat here I don't care about that I'll
get there one move later is hanging pawn
so throw some pieces here I have a
bishop that is acting for the moment
just as if it's upon but it's it's in
its controlling an important pawn
alright that move
maybe begin my work is actually a little
annoying I want to play this move
see five was kind of annoying me
if c5 taketake I have this square
there's no Bishop discovery this would
be a strong post for my queen
it would also give me a passed pawn we
both have passed pawns
if this happens 35 seconds
for first is a five there a five a three
let's see let's keep them about my eyes
open to some tricks some tactics this is
an open position
start with this move
pressure here
not going to defend this if I get there
I'm hitting a lot of stuff so there's no
time to get this guy in return I think
that may have turned out to be wasted
move the rap has to play daddy a door
push which I did not see okay wait
that weakens this square for starters so
I could play to e5 and hit both rooks
Stewart
connect one of the rooks have to go to
f8 and now I think I'm winning
I think I'm winning where the Queen
could go here no but that would drop the
bishop that's a really big square that
they gave up
I've seen that earlier after a c5 push
and a capture capture
d5 immediately I have Queenie five
oh they're capturing they're not did not
consider that
take herewith check the rook simply
returns though so
returns to f/8 but maybe that's okay
now I guess we're gonna take there's a
reason to maybe take here and keep my
structure as is but I want to be able to
crash through here
there's no Queen takes pawn I have this
no Queen g5
I don't want this bishop to establish
itself
on the d5 square
stop Quincy five check maybe right here
the pressure
pressure here hitting the clean g7
upon
take on g7 if they take on
seven for me
rook has responsibility the major pieces
both have responsibilities the bishop
should maybe move take care of a check
the Queen's up how do I get the Queens
off
the bishop moves maybe maybe I could go
back here
I should do that
Wow
I almost missed that move
the game continues I got mate though I
think I'm in the clear
they resigned why does it have to be so
tense man I almost didn't take that rook
I'm thinking if I go here there's Czech
and if I go here there's a disconnect
I'm gonna lose my queen I almost threw
my king in the corner I did not see
Queen takes rook my opponent probably
knew that I could take the rook but was
try I don't know that was a nice trick I
don't know Wow
okay final games going on still nine
let's see let's see how this one
finishes Shani
I think I think visiting Gandhi is going
to end up going perfect he's up the
exchange
more gas in the tank here
please
on a tournament
another pond this guy is going to fly
it's a check Knight takes drops a night
these guys are tricky there's a passer
black has nice coordination
yeah
I think I think that's it you have to
give up some more material the squares
we're all covered
visiting Gandhi I believe is going to go
perfect nine out of nine
I always capture there's no wrong
stuff happening no rook pawn yeah makes
it real simple
I like that approach
Impa Hovick is saying I almost beat got
this Gandhi messed up in the end should
have taken the bishop and pushed upon I
didn't I wasn't there in time to see
that that position you're referring to I
just saw the rook and pawn ending and
that's going to do it
visiting Gandhi well done
fantastic performance fantastic
26:56 winning all nine games I'm in
there with eight out of nine
and pehoe vaq taking third there were
four players in there with seven
winning on tiebreaks
Kovach
and you can see all the pages here this
is page one let's go through em all
see who else competed and how how
everyone else did thank you again
everyone who is uh
ah
competing in these I'm really I'm really
enjoying the the Swiss format
you
so
awesome turnout biggest one yet for a
Swiss that I said maybe the fifth one
I've done 181 in here
really great
you
a lot here are what what are these
considered just absent so playing some
and then saying I've had enough
okay to the 180 of you there games all
thank you all for competing imagine most
of you are just listening to the stream
so this is redundant me typing it out
now but hope you all had some good games
in there
Congrats
visiting Gandhi excellent performance
very nice
very very nice
you